well i'm stuck
so i can't
go forward it's like you don't exist
no
feel very sad
yeah very sad
moomin came to the uk as a teenage boy
12 years ago but has missed out entirely
on the rights of passage into adulthood
lost in the uk's asylum system my life
is too hard
especially i don't have any paperwork
so anyway when i go to like for the job
all these things
they need paperwork and these things
so i don't have that
moomin on the left of frame says this
picture was taken with his brothers in
afghanistan shortly before he departed
aged 14 after refusing to join the
taliban he arrived on the back of a
lorry
his lawyer says half of his time here
has been as an illegal immigrant though
he's lodged another appeal
there's a lack of data but the latest
research estimates around a million
people in total are in the uk illegally
and the overwhelming majority like
moomin did not arrive by small boat
what would you like your life to be like
i want to be like a
good businessman
yeah in future
so
and
could my own like house
and
own business
i don't have any money one pound like
i buy like chicken chips for myself
the state doesn't want moomin but his
afghan community does staying with
friends and helping in a butcher's where
they say they give him food and pocket
money the only way he can survive
he says he's had spells in college and
for a few years was allowed to work
others in the shop say they feel sorry
for moomin because he's trapped in a
life that's so unfulfilled he came to me
he said please help me and uh and that
time i help him
yeah
but not all the time i can't help him
because i have my own family as well he
tries to be happy but he can't because
you know without
document he don't have so it's very hard
not easy
so he's sad all the time
we didn't provide the home office with
moomin's details so they were unable to
address his case specifically but a
spokesperson said the government is
committed to ensuring asylum claims are
considered without unnecessary delays
and its new plan for immigration seeks
to welcome those who come through safe
and legal routes lisa holland sky news